Hervé et mime on prétend que vous êtes
le Woody Allen du barreau la star des
prêts
VIP les plus courus d'Europe pourtant
vous êtes un ténor discret et même
farouchement secret d'où vient cette
attachement viscérale au secret je
suppose qu'à l'heure de la transparence
obligatoire c'est pas juste une question
de d'esprit de contradiction non c'est
pas du tout une question d'esprit de
contradiction je crois que c'est c'est
très lié à mon caractère depuis que je
suis enfant je suis très volubile très
sociable mais au fond très secret vous
racontez d'ailleurs que le secret a été
très tôt au centre de votre existence
est-ce indiscrète nous demander pourquoi
parce que j'ai eu très vite par hasard
ou pas d'ailleurs à
recueillir les confidences confidences
en dehors de mon métier
qui était des confidences dont j'ai
considéré je crois juste titre que leur
révélation aurait pu être quasi mortel
pour la personne qui me les avait faites
quel âge avez-vous quand vous avez
recueilli ces confidences
j'avais
17-18 ans mais avant cela j'ai jamais
été dans une position ou une situation
tragique par rapport au secret mais j'ai
toujours eu un grand sens du secret
est-ce que vous connaissez ce tableau de
Magritte le double secret
non que vous évoque-t-il
alors si vous voulez j'ai une passion
pour la peinture mais une intelligence
visuelle qui est proche de zéro et je ne
comprends jamais rien à ce que je vois y
compris à ce que j'aime ou est-ce que
j'achète donc je vais vous dire la
vérité ça évoque rien alors je vais vous
raconter une anecdote qui risque
d'évoquer quelque chose comme chez vous
vous êtes si viscéralement attaché au
secret professionnel qu'au début de
votre carrière vous avez pris le risque
de laisser un tueur à gage remplir son
contrat plutôt que de le dénoncer à la
police alors là je vais vous dire une
chose ça m'est arrivé j'avais
peut-être 25 ans vous rendez compte je
me rends compte bien sûr croyais que je
m'en suis surtout rendu compte parce que
j'ai eu ça a été un problème moral
terrible
vous savez
il y a le secret il y a un attachement
viscéral au secret si vous voulez
évidemment c'est drôle de vous dire ça
en répondant interview mais moi ce que
j'aime dans la vie c'est les relations
secrètes même les relations cachées et
si je parle à quelqu'un je n'aime pas
l'idée que ce que je lui dis va pouvoir
être répété à d'autres je suis pas d'une
naïveté incommensurable et je sais très
bien c'est très bien à qui j'ai à faire
donc quand je veux quelque chose soit su
par d'autres je sais à qui le dire mais
racontez-moi cette histoire
de fou quand j'étais mais tout début je
défends commis d'office un type qui
était poursuivi pour recel c'était une
sorte de receleur professionnel qui
avait demandé je sais pas pourquoi un
avocat d'office puis quelques années
plus tard je m'installe à Paris il prend
rendez-vous avec moi il vient
et puis me dit c'était un yougoslave
avec du coffre une carrure il me dit
mettre
j'ai à vous demander conseil
oui après je vous vois et après j'ai
rendez-vous pour un contrat je dis un
contrat il me dit un contrat mais vous
avez compris je dis pardon il me dit
mais mettre voilà je dois tuer quelqu'un
et je lui dis qu'est-ce que vous voulez
comme conseil je voulais me donner votre
avis je vais vous présenter un vous
m'avez rien dit de vous n'allez tuer
personne 3 notre entretien est fini non
non maître mais je voulais et il me
donne le nom de la personne qui doit
tuer
quelqu'un connu quelqu'un de connu qui
exerçait un métier proche du mien
je suis complètement retourné
complètement retourné il était presque 8
heures du soir j'appelle Henri Leclerc
déjà à l'époque donc ça fait
pratiquement 40 ans la figure totémique
de ce métier absolument et vraiment un
homme exceptionnel en qui j'ai une
confiance absolue il y en a pas deux il
me dit fais si je fais
que vous dites
je l'imagine sur sa chaise il dit Hervé
arrête c'est n'importe quoi comment
veux-tu que ce mec te dit la vérité je
dis juste sans doute pas c'est peut-être
un mythomane complet mais il me dit
Hervé tu peux rien dire tu peux rien
faire juste à dire tu peux surtout pas
informer la personne en question tu dois
garder ta langue mais me dit-il écrit
exactement ce qui vient se passer de se
passer et va déposer ton courrier dans
la boîte aux lettres de l'ordre des
avocats à l'époque il y avait une boîte
aux lettres qui permettait dorodater les
courriers qu'on déposés et repose-toi de
plus question et il me dit si jamais le
bâtonnier réagit tu verras bien
ok je rentre chez moi je dors pas de la
nuit je dors pas de la nuit parce que
imaginez que le type Medit vrai que il
passe à l'acte et que moi je dis rien
faire le secret il aurait eu bon dos
j'aurais été dans une culpabilité Nord
mais il se passe une anecdote incroyable
alors ça je veux dire incroyable c'est
que je dors pas de la nuit le lendemain
matin je vais à la prison de la Santé à
l'époque on était très encore davantage
très matinaux il fallait y être à 8h je
suis à 8h dans le parloir de la maison
de l'arrêt de la santé j'attends que les
détenus que je dois visiter
descendent et là je croise un copain
avocat spinner Francis piner et puis
vient dans haut parleur on attend nos
détenus vous savez avant et il voit que
je suis pas dans mon assiette il me dit
qu'est-ce que tu as je suis non ça va ça
va tant que non tu as pas l'air bien non
ça va arrête tes conneries t'es pas tu
es pas dans ton assiette je suis couteau
il m'a réveillé histoire de fou etc et
je lui raconte l'histoire
il me dit
Hervé voyant tu délires comment veux-tu
que ce soit vrai à moins que ce soit
et il me donne le nom de la personne qui
m'avait dit
je n'ai plus vécu je n'ai plus vécu à
l'époque il y avait pas Google Internet
etc mais je suivais à la trace cette
personne d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'est
en lien avec ça a quitté la France à un
moment enfin bref heureusement cette
personne est en vie et j'ai su à cette
occasion le lourd tribu que l'on devait
payer au respect du secret dans notre
système français j'avais pas le droit de
faire quelque chose mais d'après vous le
secret professionnel c'est comme le
secret médical ou le secret de la
confession ça ne souffre aucune
dérogation le secret ne s'arrête pas là
où commence le respect de la vie humaine
et très fine
rhétorique extrêmement fine c'est à dire
que si vous opposez le secret de la vie
humaine si vous faites des protecteurs
du secret des assassins effectivement
c'est ça alors écoutez
je crois que le secret effectivement est
absolu
[Musique]
dans cette circonstance mais dans cette
circonstance j'avoue que il m'a posé un
problème que je n'ai pas résolu à quatre
conscience je ne me serais pas non plus
vu aller à la police pour dire ce dont
je venais d'être témoin d'autant plus
que dans dans ce dont je venais d'être
témoin il n'y avait rien qui soit des
faits palpable et qualifiables il y
avait une déclaration d'intention qui
pouvait être vrai ou pas mais oui je
suis conscient des problèmes que ça peut
poser dans des cas extrêmes parce que
par exemple si vous voulez un avocat qui
apprend que
ses clients
a commis un crime n'a pas à le dénoncer
alors qu'il y a un délit qui s'appelle
non dénonciation d'un fait qualifié
crime qui est susceptible d'être
reproché à toute personne non astreinte
au secret non soumise au secret qui est
le commettrait il faut bien comprendre
que alors le secret professionnel de
l'avocat qui est vraiment une des choses
peut-être les plus difficiles à
comprendre je crois bien que ça paraisse
très simple pour les gens qui ne sont
pas familiarisés avec cette matière
c'est quelque chose qui en fait n'est
pas une protection de l'avocat ça n'est
même pas une protection du justiciable
ça n'est pas une fonction de l'avocat
parce que l'avocat il doit le respecter
celui qui peut violer le secret c'est
l'avocat personne d'autre ça n'est pas
une protection de Justicia parce que
dans notre système français qui en
réalité va peut-être pas rester aussi
longtemps que ça
dans son intégrité on a un système qui
pictuellement émerveilleux c'est un des
rares pays un des rares système dans
lequel un client c'est un mot vilain
mais c'est le mot ne peut pas délier son
avocat du secret c'est à dire que si je
suis soumis au secret je suis votre
avocat vous me délier du secret je ne
peux pas et vous ne pouvez pas m'en
délier et le secret donc il est fait
pour protéger la justice
c'est vrai ça paraît curieux ça paraît
être grandiloquant il est frais pour
protéger l'intérêt supérieur de la
justice parce que il est le socle de la
défense vraiment le socle de la défense
et que la justice c'est une sorte
d'équilibre introuvable ou quasiment
introuvable à rechercher entre la
défense et l'accusation
et je peux vous dire Daphné que quand on
a exercé un temps soit peu ce métier
maintenant moi malheureusement c'est
plus qu'un temps soit peu on comprend
tout de suite à quel point c'est
fondamental vous venez me voir
d'ailleurs je vous dis une chose encore
aujourd'hui après presque 45 ans
d'exercice je n'en reviens pas que des
personnes qui ne me connaissent pas à
qui on a peut-être dit ils viennent ils
me racontent des trucs mais c'est délire
il ne le font que parce que au moins ils
sont convaincus que je les garderai pour
moi j'imagine quand même que l'amoureux
du secret que vous êtes peut être très
malheureux à l'heure de snapchat et de
stop covid parce que c'est presque une
cause perdue l'air du temps est plutôt
au grand déballage j'imagine que les
gens qui s'instagramment devant un plat
de pâtes en faisant lever de la victoire
ça vous rend dingue
franchement ça me fait rire je comprends
même pas ça m'amuse je trouve ça c'est
le contraire de ce que je suis vous
savez moi je vais vous dire une chose je
suis peut-être je suis peut-être un
spécimen encore plus intéressant pour
piquer la psychiatrie ou la psychanalyse
bon mais si vous voulez moi ça m'a par
exemple quand je suis dans un endroit
dans un café où il y a des gens autour
de moi j'adore par
goût de la rigolade dire parler à un
coin et dire je suis je suis là c'est
pas la un autre endroit que là où je
suis moi pour moi le fait de montrer à
tout le monde là où on est c'est le
contraire de ce que j'aime dans la vie
moi ce que j'aime c'est que personne ne
sache où je suis et là donc pour moi
c'est mais bon qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je voulais ça te date pas d'hier non
en 1997 Jean Denis brudin se plaignait
déjà que la présomption d'innocence soit
malmenée elle est en France qu'une seule
analypocrisie nul chez nous n'est
présumé innocent si tôt que le soupçon
pèse sur lui
la présomption de culpabilité ou les
trahisons du secret ne date pas dire en
fait c'est un serpent de mer alors
attendez ça vous avez tout à fait raison
et il est complètement
idiot absurde de penser que l'atteinte à
la prévention innocence et liée aux
réseaux sociaux ou à la trouver le
technologie ça peut être amplifié comme
tout par effectivement la violence des
réseaux sociaux mais non c'est pas ça
date absolument pas dire les pires
dérives du secret c'est peut-être la
faire Grégory et avant l'affaire du juge
Pascal à Bruay-en-Artois non alors
faudrait-il apporter le gars order
anglo-saxon qui permet un juge
d'interdire aux médias de la divulgation
de certains éléments d'une procédure je
crois pas c'est une c'est une très bonne
question parce que il est quasiment
inconnu ce gargor d'or des des mêmes des
juristes français je crois pas je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce que je pense
que la France est un pays incroyablement
attaché à la liberté d'expression et que
je ne souhaiterais pas moi que un juge
puisse interdire ou limiter la liberté
d'expression de médias et c'est très
compliqué parce qu'en plus je suis
personnellement mon avis importe peu
mais pas favorable du tout à un ordre
des journalistes à une déontologie
réglementé régimentée des journalistes
ce que je pense c'est qu'il y a un gros
problème dans la vraie problème dans la
façon dont les médias agissent et
réagissent à des faits divers c'est que
il y a pas toujours une une conscience
de leur responsabilité à ses grands le
vrai sujet pour moi c'est c'est la
responsabilité mais l'auto
responsabilité des mineurs il y a
absolument alors c'est particulièrement
vrai pour des faits prescrits quand les
que les médias révèlent d'effets
prescrits
c'est presque même une nécessité parce
que l'effet prescrits on sait qu'ils
pourront pas être jugés donc si je vous
disais l'effet frustrés ne peuvent
jamais être révélés ça signifie donc que
en réalité des faits prescrits et bien
ils doivent passer
indéfiniment pas seulement sur un plan
judiciaire mais aussi sur un plan
médiatique et donc finalement personnel
pour les gens qui ont pu les subir ou
pour ceux qui ont pu les commettre quand
ils ont été commis oui mais à l'inverse
et je les je les connais un stand de
fois quand un média décide de révéler
des faits prescrits c'est-à-dire de
révéler des faits dont il sait que la
personne qui est accusée ne pourra
jamais en être totalement innocenté il
faut vraiment me semble-t-il qu'ils
aient fait ou qu'il ait fait une enquête
extrêmement sérieuse qui ne prennent pas
le risque et le risque qu'il est souvent
présent et souvent gras de jeter en
pâture à l'opinion quelqu'un dont on
peut penser que la culpabilité n'est pas
certaine et j'ai vu des trucs
abominables abominable parce que là où
j'en Denis Brodin a tout à fait raison
c'est que dès que qu'un soupçon pèse sur
quelqu'un il est coupable mais bien sûr
et je vais vous dire une chose que je
pense profondément ça n'est pas capable
de faire dont on ne pourra pas le objet
coupable d'y échapper oui et mes
coupables de fait pour lesquelles on ne
pourra pas juger c'est terrible comme
situation parce qu'à la limite si vous
voulez que quelqu'un qui devrait être
présumé innocent ne soit pas oralité
considérées comme tel mais puis cette
jugée et qu'un jour il soit condamné au
moins la justice mais moi je pense que
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup rêvé
à pas grand chose mais j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi à cette notion qui m'a
passionné j'avais même acheté moi qui
suis l'anti geek j'ai acheté tous les
noms de domaine présumés innocents je
les ai encore et j'ai monté un site à un
moment oui présumé reprend mais si vous
voulez j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à ces
questions c'est facile d'accuser la
justice et les juger la justice et les
juges ont leur part de responsabilité
dans la violation de la présomption d'un
sens ou dans son non respect et le code
de prosion pénale en lui-même
c'est-à-dire que même l'application la
plus
orthodoxe du code de pénale c'est une
atteinte à la fonction innocence toute
la justice dès qu'une atteinte à ce
principe qui est censé diriger mais
on exergue de votre plaidoyer c'est
vraiment intitulé secret défense vous
citez André Malraux la vérité d'un homme
c'est d'abord ce qu'il cache est-ce que
c'est pour toucher du doigt cette vérité
que vous êtes devenu avocat avait été
mime non non c'est pas pour ça
humaine c'est le goût du paradoxe le
goût des paradoxe ambiguïté
je crois pas parce qu'il m'a attiré
c'est sans doute c'est pour ça que
j'avais un manque d'hésitation c'est
sans doute d'une manière inconsciente ce
qui m'attire aujourd'hui en partie ce
qui m'attire non je crois je vais vous
dire c'est une particulière sensibilité
à l'injustice depuis l'enfance
c'est
le goût de le goût de défendre la
détestation des accusations alors
justement le goût de défendre la défense
dans la peau avait été mis ce n'est pas
juste le titre d'un de vos livres c'est
aussi vous respirez pour et par ce
métier
vous êtes donc bien placé pour répondre
à cette question qu'est-ce que défendre
vous savez
qu'est-ce que défendre quels sont les
qualités requises pour bien défendre ça
peut vous paraître ridicule
mais cette question qui est
a priori une question d'évidence
je me la pose encore
essaye encore et je crois que j'y
arriverai jamais
de bien comprendre ce qu'est défend
défendre c'est tout faire pour essayer
je parle des formes pas dans la vie
défendre comme avocat tout faire pour
essayer
d'avoir le meilleur résultat possible
pour la personne qu'on défend dans le
plus grand respect de ce qu'elle est de
son intégrité de ce qu'elle souhaite
parce que je pourrais décliner les
raisons pour lesquelles je vous dis ça
c'est très complexe quelles sont les
qualités qu'il faut avoir pour être un
bon avocat d'abord je vais vous dire une
chose et c'est pas du tout une
coquetterie on a beau on peut se juger
comme avocat qu'en valeur relative moi
je suis pas malheureux dans mon métier
je suis épanoui en valeur relative mais
croyez-moi j'ai jamais oublié la formule
d'un immense avocat qui s'appelle
Jean-Louis Peltier qui répétant parce
que notre métier est un métier de lignée
répétant les propos oui de transmission
totalement répétant les propos des
grands avocats du de provençaux
méridionaux etc disait le meilleur
d'entre nous n'est pas à la hauteur du
métier et ça c'est vrai jamais l'oublier
mais qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on devient le
Messie ou le Zidane du Maroc parce qu'il
y en a beaucoup qui qui sont en deuxième
division mais il y a peu qui jouent en
Real Madrid vous vous jouez au Real
Madrid alors un je vais vous dire une
chose l'en
vous savez je moi j'ai la chance d'avoir
aujourd'hui une grande oui une grosse
équipe d'avocats avec moi donc je suis
un peu le coach maintenant moi mon
avenir si j'en ai un CE et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est c'est ça et je leur
dis un truc que j'ai compris avec le
temps qui est tout bête alors sauf si
vous êtes John mckenroe ou Picasso ou
Pablo Casals voilà il est quand même
rare dans la vie professionnelle qui
vous arrive des choses que vous n'ayez
pas voulu donc il faut le vouloir très
fort et c'est une envie qui est parfois
pas forcément exprimé donc l'envie et
l'ambition mais l'ambition son stuff du
terme alors vous détestez vous êtes
joueur vous détestez perdre et vous êtes
un champion du calcul mental et de
l'arithmétique est-ce que justement un
dossier ça relève aussi de l'équation
mathématique alors
je déteste perdre vous savez j'ai
compris j'ai toujours aimé je suis un
très très bon
un piètre sportif mais par contre dans
mon fauteuil ou dans les stades où à la
télé je suis vraiment d'un niveau
exceptionnel et et j'avais une
idole au tennis qui était John mckennon
et j'ai lu un jour une biographie John
McEnroe par Richard Evans et j'ai tout
compris et ça correspondait à ce que je
ressentais à mon tout petit niveau de
joueurs de tennis non je plaisant et
d'avocat mais j'ai joué en fait
c'est pas son lien avec le côté joueur
parce que joueur c'est un peu le mythe
de Sisyphe c'est pas aimé perdre c'est
aimer sauvé en fait ce qu'on aime c'est
moins gagner
que détester perdre ce qui prend le pas
c'est la détestation de la défaite ça
peut vous rendre malade comment rit
Leclerc vous parlez d'Henri Leclerc je
vais vous dire oui par exemple je pense
j'ai bien j'ai bien réfléchi à tout ça
Henri Leclerc qui est probablement un
avocat ou d'exception qui est notre
référence comme vous le disiez et bien
je crois que ça plus grande qualité
c'est ça c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'échec
dont ils dont ils ne se soit senti
directement responsable pouvoir coupable
et ça si vous n'êtes pas prêt à assumer
la responsabilité totale d'un échec vous
pouvez pas gagner et vous savez je dis
ça avec le sourire mais c'est pas drôle
l'échec pour nous c'est grave c'est dur
parce que l'échec c'est pas simplement
des tomates on nous parfois nous on nous
compare et c'est pas idiot avec des
comédiens ou avec des des gens c'est pas
les les tomates ou les mauvaises
critiques c'est voilà c'est la vie d'un
homme ou d'une femme qui est qui est
gâchée dont vous vous dites que si vous
aviez
défendu différemment son cas ça aurait
pu être autre chose vous parlez du jeu
vous vous méfiez de la lumière mais vous
ne dédaignez pas le cinéma vous avez vu
dans les films d'Audiard Maïwenn
dernièrement dans les choses humaines de
Yvan Attal l'avocat serait-il un
comédien contrarié
il y a un peu de ça j'avais écrit dans
mon bouquin à défendre dans la peau
j'avais écrit un chapitre pour en disant
l'avocat ronde cuir ou saltimbanque on
est un peu des deux je vais vous dire il
faut être capable de il faut être
capable de d'être un peu sévère avec
soi-même non je me suis pas de la
lumière je je suis conscient du fait que
mon métier est un métier où je je j'ai
des affaires extrêmement sérieuses on
doit m'occuper des clients extrêmement
sérieux importants donc je fais pas
n'importe quoi mais j'aime la lumière je
suis attiré par la lumière il y a une
part de jeu dans une plaidoirie parce
que je sais que vous faites ça le comble
à chacune de vos audiences j'aimerais
bien mais non non
jusqu'à dire que vous donnez envie de
commettre un crime rien
que pour vous voir à l'oeuvre alors ça
me fait penser à ma grand-mère qui
va non attendez tout ça non je vais vous
dire une chose
par deux jeux non
[Musique]
c'est triste parce que ça fait ça a pas
changé depuis tant d'années c'est ce que
je préfère faire au monde voilà
parce que j'ai eu la chance de d'avoir
une vocation pour un métier que je
connaissais pas alors une vocation
est-ce que vous étiez près destiné parce
que votre ancien confrère
Eric Dupond-Moretti affirme que je n'ai
pas on ne vient pas avocat pénaliste par
hasard on a un compte à régler est-ce
que vous avez des comptes à régler oui
je pense bien sûr je pense alors moi
j'ai pas du tout une revanche sociale
c'est pas du tout de ce type là je pense
que oui c'est évident bon mais j'ai eu
le temps d'en parler déjà une fois donc
vous en parle une fois vous en parlez
toujours
oui le fait par exemple d'avoir perdu
votre père jeune c'est évident quand on
est confronté à la souffrance jeune
c'est un c'est une chance pour un avocat
d'une certaine manière aussi paradoxale
que ça puisse parler
c'est une chance c'est une chance pour
tout être humain si on peut en sortir
moi j'en suis sorti très vite c'est une
chance ouais bien sûr c'est une chance
d'une richesse je n'ai jamais eu dans ma
vie d'Atom crochus jamais avec des
hommes ou des femmes qui n'est pas connu
la souffrance je n'ai jamais ri vraiment
à gorge déployer je peux avoir des fous
rires sans fin avec des hommes ou des
femmes qui n'ont pas un sens profond de
ce qui est désespérant dans la vie Henri
Leclerc affirme qu'on ne plaide jamais
que pour soi
je l'ai entendu dire ça il y a très
longtemps déjà
c'est vrai mais
[Musique]
oui on est ce qui est vrai c'est que on
est toujours soit quand on plaide je le
dirai plutôt comme ça moins bien qu'en
riz mais je vous dis il y a toujours
raison mais non mais je dirais ça plutôt
on est toujours soit quand on plaide
voyez c'est peut-être d'ailleurs une des
différences qui peut y avoir avec un
comédien qui joue des rôles ou pas un
rôle un avocat qui joue un rôle est un
mauvaise avocat un avocat qui en fait
trop ces gros tests un avocat qui qui
endosse un costume trop large pour lui
il est à côté de la plaque mais non je
je pense oui on est toujours soi-même
quand on plaide Hervé l'opinion publique
exige ces temps-ci de plus en plus
réparation à la justice or vous ne
croyez pas aux vertus thérapeutiques du
procès pénal n'est-ce pas
ça n'est pas le lieu ce n'est pas son
rôle c'est pas que je crois pas aux
vertus thérapeutiques du procès pénal il
peut y avoir des vertus thérapeutiques
au procès pénal il peut y avoir aussi
des dégâts horribles à l'occasion de
procès pénal causé à des victimes ou à
des plaignants je crois que
malheureusement il faut avoir le courage
de dire et d'admettre que ça n'est pas
la fonction de la justice la justice n'a
pas pour but de réparer des dégâts la
justice elle a pour but de chercher la
vérité et de dire si oui ou non les les
hommes et les femmes qui sont déférés
devant elles sont coupables
se font en dehors de la reine judiciaire
de plus en plus c'est le tam-tam et le
tribunal médiatique qui s'enchaînés oui
mais
la justice justement c'est pour ça que
je suis moi un ardent défenseur des
juges avec qui j'ai parfois des
et parfois des audiences souleuses des
rapports extrêmement violents dans
certains cas mais j'ai j'ai beaucoup de
je défends avec ardeur les juges et j'ai
je mets en avant j'exalte même leur rôle
parce que face au tribunal médiatique il
paraît que ça existe pas tu parles face
au tribunal médiatique qu'est-ce qu'on
peut attendre qu'est-ce qu'on peut
espérer à l'application de la loi et
qu'il applique les juges donc vous avez
raison c'est un des travers de l'époque
il a toujours existé ce travers mais
c'est un travers marquant de l'époque je
dirais amplifié par les réseaux sociaux
oui voilà mais mais mais mais la justice
les juges savent parfois résister auprès
du jugement médiatique je ne fais pas
partie des avocats qui considèrent que
le jugement médiatique ou le pré
jugement médiatique est nécessairement
confirmé par le jugement judiciaire je
pense même que très souvent je vous
parle pas de stratégie très élaborée
elle a un je ne dévoile pas de secret de
fabrication si d'ailleurs il y en a mais
je crois que même souvent il faut savoir
jouer les juges contre les médias
une question importante que votre client
soit innocent ou coupable est-elle la
question finalement ce qui prime est-ce
que c'est le respect du droit et non la
recherche de la vérité qu'est-ce qui
prime
très bien c'est ça qui fait que il est
difficile d'y répondre en une phrase
pour un avocat
ça n'est pas la vérité qui prime c'est
choquant mais si la vérité prime pour
vous
il faut pas être avocat il faut être
policier ou juge ça ne veut pas dire et
là encore je suis minoritaire qui a
beaucoup d'avocats vous disent que la
vérité des intéresse pas moi ça n'est
pas mon cas c'est à dire que la vérité
ne vous intéresse pas mais ce qui compte
pour un avocat c'est le respect du droit
et le droit c'est quoi c'est que une
personne contre laquelle l'épreuve
réunit ne sont pas suffisantes ne soit
pas condamnées voilà est-ce que on
demande la vérité à nos clients non pas
toujours non pas toujours parfois oui
quand je considère que
s'il me manque il se font du tort même
c'est à dire que il y a des espaces de
confiance entre un avocat et son client
qui sont des espaces parfois vitaux
il y a des choses où vous n'avez pas le
droit de monter parce que si vous mentez
et bien vous faites du tort mais vous
savez
et ça les juges parfois le comprennent
mal les avocats même s'ils recherchent
pas la vérité sont de formidables à
coucheurs de la vérité parce que comment
on arrive par exemple à faire en sorte
que quelqu'un qui soutient
l'insoutenable ne le soutiennent plus
pas du tout pas du tout en lui disant
m'attendait vous racontez n'importe quoi
vous mentez dites moi la vérité mais en
le mettant quelque sorte échec et mat
par rapport aux éléments du dossier par
rapport aux réponses qui pourra avoir à
donner à des questions si j'avais le
temps j'ai tellement d'anecdotes à
mourir de rire là-dessus pour certains
pédaliste être du côté des parties
civils c'est trahir l'essence même du
métier vous vous avez été plus souvent
sur le banc de la défense que du côté
des parties civils c'est un regret non
c'est j'ai été pas j'ai pas été plus
souvent j'ai été beaucoup plus souvent
sur les bancs de la défense
oui d'abord je pense que si vous voulez
plaider le vent dans le dos c'est comme
ne pas plaider mais
vous savez vous parler de c'est vrai
c'est une expression que j'ai utilisé
mais regardez c'est on fait une
métaphore sportive si vous sautez en
longueur ou vous courez à 100 m et si le
vent est à 2 mètres supérieur à 2 mètres
par seconde et ben votre corps est pas
homologué plaider le vent dans le dos
c'est donc
pas du tout en revanche je n'irai pas du
tout jusqu'à dire que plaider du côté
est partie ville c'est trahir le métier
d'avocat certainement pas il y a
certaines pas certains avocats de partie
civils qui exercent leur fonction
d'avocats partie vie d'une manière qui
est méprisable mais il y a des cas de la
défense qu'ils font aussi d'une manière
méprisable non non il faut pas aller
dans ces caricatures là mais moi mes
modèles c'est
Badinter Leclerc avant
Polak Moreau diafferi les grands c'est
ça que j'aime moi j'aime les gens qui
défendent puis la fonction social du
lanceur d'alerte elle est capitale
celle de défense celui qui est accusé
celui qui est dans une position
difficile voilà c'est ça que j'aime mais
ça n'est pas du tout que je ne respecte
pas d'autres approches du métier
d'autres conceptions du métier et que je
me considère la fonction sociale des des
lanceurs d'alerte le courage qu'il leur
faute notre métier est un métier très
particulier très très particulier
j'aimerais et conclure et vous laissez
le mot de la fin comment expliquer vous
qui est une telle crise d'évocation dans
votre métier c'est derrière années
qu'attendez-vous à la fois de la justice
et qu'auriez-vous envie de dire à tous
les apprentis à votre cas vous savez je
vais vous dire une chose vous n'imaginez
même pas à quel point il y a un appel
d'évocation pour la défense pénale c'est
inouï le nombre de jeunes avocats qui
veulent faire du pénal le nombre
aujourd'hui
je pense j'ai écouté l'autre jour
je sais plus qui s'était parce que
j'écoute tellement de podcasts etc la
radio c'est merveilleux aussi comme ça
un type qui expliquait qu'en fait on a
toujours l'âge on a toujours l'âge de
son traumatisme quand on a vécu
mais moi j'en ai dit je n'ai pas changé
je n'ai pas changé d'un iota depuis le
jour où j'ai perdu mon père et je suis
resté le même et avec la même naïveté le
même enthousiasme je leur dirai soyez
avocats c'est le plus beau métier du
monde la réalité dépassera vos rêves les
plus fous c'est un métier merveilleux et
le meilleur d'entre nous n'est pas à la
hauteur du métier merci merci à vous